alors ce tour de magie consiste en quoi
alors belle carte à jouer
oui j'aimerais qu'ils me nomment une
carte à jouer celle que tu veux c'est
tout le monde ouvertement web que ton
père sa mère et moi je vais le dire
ouvertement je vais le dire devant les
français 9 de carreau bim dans le
culture il à l'époque mais on n'a pas vu
et là je ne change pas c'est le 9 de
carreau donc oui d'accord mais
évidemment le 9 de carreau enfants à
tout le monde a une image de ce que cbc
imaginaire on n'a pas de 9 de carreau
sous la main qu'on peut toujours faire
les pas si imaginaire par contre si je
sors un jeu de kart wii et que j'isole
le 9 de carreau du jeu à ce moment là on
aura quelque chose de banal pas
normalement pas dans un jeu de cartes on
va voir le dos 1 voilà par contre on
veut pas le faire avec ce jeu c'est
pourquoi parce que c'est un jeu de
cartes qui n'a pas encore été les bleus
et tiens je vais parce que tu aimes tant
que tu avais un cyril donc mais pas moi
de losail mais bordel de ces cartes
pourrait être le 9 de carreau trois sets
car cela elle est blanche
elle est blanche mais je vais te demande
et cyril le d'imaginer que cette carte
n'est pas blanchi imagine toi tu es
c'est un oeuf de caille à cordes comme
dans la main comme ça parfait vers le
haut
parce que je vais y placer la mer c'est
mon scanner un peu plus bas voilà bien
jusqu'à la 4e place et on pousse
par-dessus peut-être juste pour la jupe
à 4 ongles parfaits il imagine toi que
cette carte n'est plus une carte blanche
imagine toi que c'est le neuf de coeur
ou de thomas coeur
[Applaudissements]